Here, we will talk
about in the calculation
of angular momentum.
People often forget
that angular momentum
can be calculated
for any object,
even for an object
that's traveling
in a straight line and
not rotating at all.
For example, here
I have an object
with mass m moving at a
speed v along a street line.
Another important
thing to keep in mind
is that angular momentum does
not have a definite value.
It depends on the choice of
origin, which is arbitrary,
although some choices
are easier to calculate
or more useful than others.
Here, I will choose this
completely random point
to be my origin.
Notice that it can be
any point in space.
Angular momentum is
a lot like torque.
They both involve a cross
product of a distance vector
with another vector.
For angular momentum, it's
the distance vector r,
the vector from the
origin to the object,
cross p, the momentum
of the object, or mv.
Once again, we can
write the magnitude
of this cross-product as
r times mv times the size
of the theta between the two.
But it's often more
helpful to think
about this as r times
sine theta times mv.
In other words, the r sine
theta is the component
of the position vector that's
perpendicular to the direction
of the momentum.
Let's practice with
a few other examples.
If I have a ball moving up and
I have my origin at the side,
then this is the
perpendicular distance.
So the angular momentum is
r perpendicular times mv.
A reference point that's
the same horizontal distance
away from the object will see
the same angular momentum.
Notice that in this case,
the angular momentum is not
changing as the ball moves,
because the perpendicular
distance is not
changing with time.
In this case, if the ball
is moving at an angle,
we again, have to
take the perpendicular
component of the position vector
to find the angular momentum.
This second reference point is
now a different distance away.
So the angular
momentum is larger.
Now, let's talk about the
sign of angular momentum.
You can calculate the
sine of a cross product
with the right hand rule.
Make sure your vectors
are tail to tail when
you compare the directions.
So in this case, we have that
r cross v points into the page.
In the case of circular
motion, r and v
are always perpendicular.
So we can just multiply
the magnitudes together.
And the sine tells us which way
we're going around the circle.
If we consider out of
the page to be positive
and the angular
momentum is positive,
then the object is
circulating counter-clockwise.
If the angular
momentum is negative,
the object is
circulating clockwise.